probably lived like half my life God
bless you know what I'm saying so you
know even when I talk on tapes now like
you know the things I say at 45 I wasn't
saying in 20 and I'm like but I'm also
thinking about like wow what I'm you
know I'm I'm I'm leaving behind or I'm
I'm leaving a legacy
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast I am
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys guys this is the dope
usual podcast we're gonna talk about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between today's a very
special guest if you can't see Marty's
smile today's the DJ Drama episode thank
you for being here thanks for having me
appreciate you coming absolutely uh if
you can't tell by this man's smile every
year he's legendary yeah this is season
three okay Marty doesn't listen to music
uh
they only listen to East Coast where
he's like I'll just you know it's the
same Loop so we finally have someone
here that Marty listens to every five
seconds bro he's uh I didn't realize
I've been listening to the same playlist
basically since 2005
playlists existed yeah exactly but I
realized at the gym like damn there's DJ
Drama in the back of like 80 of my
playlist still that I listen to to this
day I appreciate it thank you man
absolutely I really saw something I
appreciate that appreciate it we're
going to get started right away Marty
why don't you bust that out yeah okay
let's get started
so it was the Bay episode
Thomas brought about 10 mixtapes oh I I
go I like underground yeah spending all
my money from weed on CDs yeah
is that still out no because that was in
the bay yeah is it still there I have no
idea you start going street light my
cousin started managing street light
records so I just went there forever got
you I remember things in there I mean
but yep yeah I was a kid yeah you know
we we saw because we've been doing our
research obviously and Scottish man
gangster girls your brand yes we have
over 150 plus gangster grills my 250.50
okay okay yeah like 250 games the
numbers have gone up yeah in many
different ways out there in the world
and I saw you rank your top projects
which must be really hard to do because
people ask us to do that with our
episodes yeah it's possible got you how
many episodes do I have oh this is
season three we're at like 1 20. oh yeah
so 15. have you ever done it have you
ever ranked it's too hard bro because
it's like how are you feeling in that
moment
exactly yeah they're all very special
but thankfully we don't have hundreds of
kids
yeah no just keep it that way
you just had his 11th time I wonder if
he can rank him
I don't think you would want to and
every time he sits down in my house he
just falls asleep
they're all homeschooled and they all
play an instrument of sport oh that's
dope though but it's like dude all your
all of them you gotta run it like that
at that point we're gonna have a team
yeah pool Jackson five of them
yeah oh put something together do you
smoke
um just today you just Vape yeah do you
mind if we smoke no get get busy
because we I really smoked a few people
out I don't want to ruin their day I
mean I do smoke but I'm not I'm not a
big smoker and then like there's certain
things I do like DJing interviews things
like that like I rarely ever will I
smoke yeah yeah it's just like
I like to keep my composure yeah that's
what I wanted to ask for example but I
mean by all means get busy just blow
smoke around you and I'm assuming this
is like a normal occurrence for the show
yes yeah yeah we uh we smoke a lot of
weed yeah well don't judge me for this
instructions
it's a bad hat it's one of my few very
bad habits you used to smoke cigs I
never smoked cigarettes I did smoke and
then but I've been smoking weed since I
was like 13 but you know I've given up
some other narcotics thankfully so you
know I just I keep this as mine like the
habits you won't get you I used to I do
a lot of shrooms though do you yeah yeah
like if y'all broke out some chocolate
bars right now I'd be all in damn well
I'm sorry I have so many shrooms in my
house I'd have been all in yeah during
the episode
like for sure
I just don't want to assume like your
chocolates or gummies I've been ready to
go
how often is that part of your routine
um I went to a phase where I was I was
doing shrooms daily like oh like I would
like her dose yeah micro dosing take a
bar maybe take like um like uh three
three bars at a time and then just
during the day I'll just by the end of
the day I've gotten through a whole bar
so um I still do it I mean it's still uh
a regular like I'd say daily or you know
do you ever other than ever take
mushrooms for the intent of like I'm
gonna turn my phone off and I'm Gonna
Leave Earth for a while now I in the
past I mean when I used to do like the
real shrooms I've been there and then
um probably most recently
um one morning I had a flight and I just
I think I was like kind of like half
sleep and I was kind of I guess I
thought it was breakfast and I just like
ate a whole bar so I like my flight was
like Star Trek so that was pretty ill
but it was fun
um I don't know fun would be the word I
don't like being around that many people
no yeah it was too intense especially in
a caps yeah yeah I mean thankfully I had
like a like a one of the bed seats but
it was like it was just too much going
on like I couldn't even focus I I
literally thought I was on Star Trek but
um but I I do like to just micro dose
during the day just make sure everything
feel like eventful you know what I'm
saying even in this no that's cool I was
talking about it last night to my homie
because when I eat mushrooms I probably
you know it came to like four or five
Grands but I'm like trying to I'm trying
to trip it's not so often not so often I
haven't done that in a while like I
should I really want to like maybe go to
the beach or something and like just
take like a whole bar like
bug out whole bar is what two grams oh
those chocolate bars I think so yeah see
my mom micro doses like every other
morning now really she's going hard with
that wow and she loves it so I so she's
like it just adds something like okay
that's how I like to explain it I mean
but like what is it like and I'm like
it's just like it just makes everything
feel like an event a little elevated
yeah everything's a little more
important my my best friend my business
partner like he's he like smokes a lot
and like
like I've never seen somebody like
maintain and be able to like keep a
composure and handle business to that
extent like if I smoke I'll it'll like I
can't wake up and smoke like I just my
day slows down like but I respect people
who can smoke and still like maintain at
a certain level of intellect you know
what I'm saying for sure that's what I I
I I'm impressed by I think it's the the
people used to play with packs a lot so
you know I used to sell pack so I think
that's why my I'm one of the highest
Tolerance on Earth for real like I do
YouTube I do all the other videos that's
what I do yeah and sometimes when my mom
was here yesterday I smoked a hash Ross
and Joint she hit it once it was dying
yeah and I smoked it and we left and go
I'm really not hot that's crazy it's
like a six gram join like I'm high but
I'm I'm driving that's crazy I'm fine I
just feel like it would be nice to get
hot and just wake up oh yeah the week
that's how I was 15 years old yeah so
we're closer to Coffee damn near yeah it
is this is part of my routine you like
make do meetings while I'm smoking bowls
I'm impressed it's just the uh I think
it's just the the certain people you
know I'm saying certain people like my
mom's takes micro doses I'm not doing
this but but oh so you you couldn't do
that every day one of Michael does every
day because I feel like
I run like six businesses yeah
interesting you know wait what today
what's today but for me like it wasn't
even like I don't know I don't even feel
like my tolerance even during times when
I did smoke a lot like like my tolerance
went up or anything like I still would
like if I smoke a backwood like four or
five hits in I'm there like if I smoke
the whole backwood I'm no matter what
I'm going down that's the best balance
of Life yeah I feel
you can
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our sponsors and this is
fume be smart don't start kick the habit
put it out before it puts you out you've
heard these phrases hundreds of times
throughout your life yet you still
choose to have a bad habit our sponsor
fumes on a mission to accelerate
Humanity's breakup from the bad habits
that consume far too many of us fume is
a natural effusive device that uses
natural plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habits
for a positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
help you transform your negative habits
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a fume uses cores
filled with plants like cinnamon and
mint for delicious natural flavor Doom's
new version 2 is Snappy high quality and
overall just looks really nice with an
adjustable airflow dial and magnetic end
cap your fingers will always have
something to do the easiest way to stop
a bad habit is to switch to a positive
one and fume has made it extremely easy
for you to do that fume's number one
goal is to make switching easy and
enjoyable so head to trifum.com and use
code Dau to get a 10 off the journey
pack today the journey pack comes with
three unique flavors and the new version
2 fume to help you kick start your
positive habits so guys that's
trifum.com
t-r-y-fum.com and use our code at
checkout Dau for 10 off the journey pack
today
foreign
[Music]
this is a public service announcement as
you know manscape has just introduced
beard products but they've gone even
further and here's the weed whacker 2.0
so the leaders in the below the waist
hygiene products manscape is going up
north to the beard products guys there
are multiple items manscape just dropped
beard hedger Pro kit the bomb the
scissors but the new weed whacker 2.0
and the new beard line for manscape
they've cemented their spot as having
the best hygiene tools for your hygiene
toolbox time for you to upgrade your
game by going to manscape.com Yola for
20 off and free shipping use code Yola
checkout it all starts with the new
cordless electric beard hedger the beard
hedger is tough on hair smooth on your
face with a single stroke efficiency one
stroke at a time Marty it's waterproof
cordless trimmer has a rotary wheel that
gives you 20 cutting lengths with one
dial no more need for messy drawers with
tons of little clips and extensions for
your trimmer so new for manscape Beard
shampoo beard conditioner beard balm to
make sure you're staying healthy you're
not just dry after you shave plus right
now it comes with three free gifts
that's a beard brush comb has scissors
like we said last week to make you just
feel a little more like Captain Hook so
get 20 off in free shipping with code
Yola that's manscape.com Yola to get 20
off and free shipping with the world's
best ball trimmer slash beard trimmers
you can get always use the right tools
for your tool manscapes you can
[Music]
Mark you want to bust those out real
quick yeah yeah so we're gonna be he's
into this he's into this you ranked in
double XL I believe uh dedication is
your top gangster girls if you had to
choose I mean it was between dedication
two and like trap or die I think those
are always like the one in the two
that'll go back and forth on and it's
like you've seen I was thinking about if
you were a Think and Grow Rich by
Napoleon Hill uh yes he interviewed 500
millionaires and tried to find a through
line between all like all their success
what was it late nights late nighters I
mean it's the whole book but I was
thinking about how similar it is with
you that you've gotten to experience so
many different artists in so many
different facets like when you pick
those top two is that because like are
they was like something different about
those sessions or how they were in the
booth or what
um I think more of it
because to be honest as of recently like
I'm probably gonna start having to put
Tyler the Creator call me if you get
lost in those top
um obviously it was Grammy Award winning
so that was the major portion of it as
well as the genius of the project but
when I think about mixtapes like the
reason why I put dedication to and that
space is because like to me it's like
it was when I
came to like
a culmination of like the perfect
mixtape like when I think about like
Wayne and his Prime and like what where
he was lyrically and like body in those
records where I was as far as like my
talk game or just like even little
things that I did on the tape as far as
like how I would like kind of like start
off a song and cut it off then go to
another song and come back to it or like
putting a secret song on there like at
the end and just like you know or even
like the the skits of of him talking
like how when I think about that tape
and how it was put together it's like a
Flawless mixtape to me
um trap or die I feel like is somewhat
of the blueprint of like what quality
Street Music is what like a lot of what
happened in trap music or you know
because of trap or die while my career
took an Ascension and like why people
wanted to do mixtapes with me period
like because like the combination of me
and Jeezy and what that tape was was
like you know it was the street
blueprint in a lot of ways so
um you know I've done so many tapes
since those that are are incredible
bodies of work and like even when I go
back and listen to it like you know like
20 or what was that 05 so almost 20
years later like obviously I've matured
I've grown I've gotten better in so many
ways with how I um attack projects but
like when we talk about mixtapes and at
a time in the space of what the mixtape
game was like those two are just like
top of the food chain you know and those
are the tapes that most people
whether I run into them or online or in
interviews those are the the two that
come up the most
and people might not really understand
when they hear the word DJ like when you
curate an album yeah the role that you
play and everything from start to finish
that like is even way more than the
artist a lot of the time I would imagine
because you're doing the producers
you're curating all the songs make
putting the whole vision for that
project together that's what makes it a
gangster girls absolutely
um obviously for me I always like
you know give them I like to say the
artist is the main focus because it's
it's it's like
being a director so it's like they're
the star they're the actor it's it's
Scorsese directing Leonardo or or Pacino
or De Niro or something
um so you know I play the role into you
know making sure like when it comes to
production or when it comes to
sequencing or the bells and the whistles
or you know I work I work off the artist
a lot of times so when I hear them you
know say a certain thing or you know
name a certain song something like
that's going to be the direction I take
and you know what I say on the project
so
um yeah I mean at the end of the day you
know the most what gangster girls is
known for is is normally based around a
particular artist but I play that like
director role in a sense do you feel
like it's less collaborative now and
like with phones and everything the way
it is versus like the actual mixtape era
between you and the artist um um not not
necessarily I mean because you know
depending on what the who the artist is
or you know how like the time and the
space like there's been recent projects
that I've done like
been in the studio with the artists
Simba's tape I did with him
um just recently like me me and uh G
Perico did a hot shot you know I was in
the studio with them working with Tyler
I was you know we did that whole thing
together like my portion so
um
a majority of the time like throughout
throughout the history of gangster girls
like a lot of times like there'll be
times when we'll be in the studio
working on the music but then like when
I go and do my my part I always like to
be in my own space in my own zone so
that's been something that I've like
I've always I've always done even from
then to now for the most part but there
are some artists that you know have
called upon or you know because of
whatever circumstances I'm in there and
you know I'm I'm doing it right on the
spot so I like it both ways yeah that
makes sense but y'all still haven't
broken out with Justin
so my top five my personal okay I'm
trying to break out my top five yeah
okay just as a fan up top
is this an order or an order this is in
no particular order Willie the kid when
you came out with the Affiliates early
on hit the mixtape scene heavy wow that
[__] is still in my playlist out of
Grand Rapids that's the other point I
wanted to make while he's working with
all these Superstars he's going and
we're to Detroit into Grand Rapids into
Buffalo into the littler markets even
like G Perico now like he's what I was
always respected was not just going for
the superstars yeah the artist who
really liked it I mean I think that's
been like a highlight of what people
respect and like why I am where I am in
my career because you know a lot of my
tapes or a lot of the artists I work
with have been
not all the time a-listers at the point
where I work with them like I've done so
many tips with so many people that have
become Superstars like when I did little
babies tape like it was early on in his
career obviously like Jeezy gangster
girls was his first platform like you
know I could go on for days with with
artists that kind of like
broke because of Yo Gotti like we did it
say super early on
um there's not many people in music that
there's like have broke or been a part
of more artists careers I feel like
that's a fact that's a fact I'm
definitely one of those one of those
guys and um and I think that's what you
know as a DJ
I feel like that's you know part of a
DJ's responsibility and in some senses
like you know we're the medium between
the music and the people and then like
as a mixtape DJ like that was always my
thing like just being addicted to the
new [__] so for me like being able to
have an eye or an ear or like the vision
for the talent and what's about to
happen or like rest in peace nipsy like
when we did Crenshaw like that was a a
very turning point in nipsey's career
like that you know that that's the
project that you know and of course he
had a fan base
uh up to that that point uh as well but
you know Crenshaw was a a big project
for nip so you know and being a part of
that like I just I just love being a
part of like new movements and like new
[__] and then you know what I'm saying
because
you know I tell artists all the time
even to this day December's another one
like you know he's he's on the rise and
like when we did uh results take time
like you know as much as they love
working with me or it's a an honor or
like you know a dream a part of their
bucket list to do a gangster girls like
you know the the success of them at that
space when we do that project just makes
me look all the more genius yeah
like oh drama
all right he's got the eye so moving on
for me top like workout music
combination of an artist damn they're in
their Prime with the rare production
there is no competition one not number
one for me fabulous champ is here part
three championships then you're my
favorite mixtape Of All Times
Marty's what's up
and just to clarify which Willie to kid
tape
that was um
what was that called divide and conquer
that was the one with me and Big Mike I
think yeah yep okay yeah but anyway is
there anything behind those fat the
fabulous and Jadakiss projects that a
Super Fan might not know that might want
to know about working with them
um so I always felt like
uh there is no competition one was was
somewhat of like a underappreciated tape
it came at a time like after the quote
Infamous raid that um you know like I
don't know if it got the attention that
it deserved
um on that tape
um there's definitely like some Jabs on
this some shots I'm not going to say
tour too but me and a certain artists
were going through some things at the
time and you know I took a couple shots
on the tape I remember just randomly
naming it there is no competition and
then you know I was just just recently
talking to Fab about that and just like
about the the second one in the series
how he really got into mode that's how
he came up with funeral Fab like you
know it was almost like there were three
names for that so it was like a gangster
grills then it was there was no
competition and then part two was like
the funeral series because we were
killing a competition
um so that was it that was a fun Series
yeah legendary all-time greats for
all-time great artists the Jadakiss
you know
when we did that because you know I
remember when when green and kiss did
the first chap is here like you know I'm
growing up
are like even you know in my early years
of gangster girls like me and canon in a
sense like we were we were the biggest
Green Lantern fans like he was the Green
Lantern um
[__] in Upstate New York right
yeah shot the green like he was he was
the mixtape goat to us like between
green and who kid like we we studied
everything they did so a lot of like
even what how gangster girls
started or like how I approached it with
the drops and just like
just a lot of a lot of that really came
from Green Lantern influence and
inspiration so to be a part of The champ
is here series
um you know is is like was it was
legendary and a lot of people don't know
that that's where the uh Infamous who
shot You Freestyle that he performed at
the versus uh comes from it came from
that tape hmm
common knowledge of me I don't know it's
me good morning all right so I got two
pieces of vinyl here I want to bust out
just maybe see if you got some stories
very near and dear to me you guys put
this together straight out of Buffalo
New York my hometown yeah finding the
BSF Gangsta Grill Syndicate crazy came
out three years ago right yep
Benny it's funny because Benny um Benny
and Gunn have recently said like they
don't get the credit for the gangster
girls Resurgence so right before we did
this uh gun actually had me do an intro
for uh one of the um Hitler wears Hermes
projects and then me and Benny did this
yeah we did it in 2020 like during covet
so this was kind of
ahead of the gangster girls with
surgeons curve in a sense like you know
Benny just put on like I'm I'm the one
that got DJ Drama out his executive bag
and he's he's not wrong like you know he
came to me to you know wanting to do
this project as a gangster girls and uh
this is super you know to see this on
vinyl it's super fire so crazy right
yeah and he turned around and put him on
the track with Fab and Jim Jones
absolutely
um I put him on the forever track uh
with uh with Fab and Jim and then you
know that's that's that song is how I
came up with my the title for my album
I'm really like that because in in Jim's
bar
ends his bar with you know saying I'm
really like that and I was like oh yeah
that's the title put out and there it is
right there and this is dope like uh
it's over
um Cannon produced that a super did a
video for that did you have any
experiences with DJ Shay
uh I did yep she's alleging to me he put
I did music I came up with mixtapes he
put me on the radio back in the day very
special
great guy he was he was there while we
was um working on this you know he was
at the video shoots he was you know
super super dope dope dude always show
love and you know just a genuine dude
you know what I'm saying so yeah and I I
had known him for for some time even
before this you know just like even uh
going to Buffalo for gigs and stuff
when's your first connect with Benny
when did I first connect with Benny
um
I don't know it's been some years but um
I've known these I've known these guys
for for a long time
um even through my connection with uh uh
Willie the Kidd and they had a homeboy
who uh who did clothes so like gun
reminded me that like he had he had been
around he had came to like my old Studio
that I had
um before I built mean Street Studio so
you know we've been we've been crossing
paths for for quite some time so I've
known Benny for some years that sucks
just as a fan of music I always
appreciated that like putting on Buffalo
and [__] not even a Griselda piece but
one for the BSF piece for sure not you
know I mean again you know Benny came to
me he was like yo I want to you know
showcase my team and I was like let's
run it respect I was sick and then last
one you mentioned it already we just
held the Russell on here and he's
following the same model so there's
still Echoes on today they're proud to
pay most legendary one of the most
legendary first hundred dollar album of
all time
Innovative projects to come out DJ DJ
Drama presents bro I've never seen this
on vinyl never so do you have you don't
have all your own projects on Vineland I
don't have this wow crazy yeah the
photography everything is just iconic
about this project you're talking about
the hidden tracks
the uh the last track on this is Daniel
my favorite song of all time and then it
bleeds into two hidden tracks which is
damn near one of my favorite tracks of
all time too like he's talking about am
I on this vinyl do you know I see it
says DJ I don't even own the turntable I
would assume so wow this is crazy see I
mean this is why I have a big CD
collection this tangible [__] I feel
like you appreciate that more yeah you
listen to the project fully through you
know what I'm saying yeah this is so
fire like you listen to this so the way
this came about was I was in LA randomly
um I used to be a Wokcano it was on
Third Street there was a volcano on
Third Street
um me and my uh partner Lake went to go
get some food there I'm not sure if if I
think Dre Sinatra happened to be with us
too and I ran into nip uh nycano
had no nip for some years already
um like and nip had a relationship too
and we just started chopping it up we
were just you know having combo and I
was like yo it feels like Tom like what
you want to do you know what I'm saying
he was like yo he's like it's crazy I
ran into you I got this i got this dope
concept and I think it would be the
perfect time to do let's do the gangster
girls and I was like let's run it and it
turned into Crenshaw you know which
which was a a legendary project you know
in so many ways like you know Nick came
to Atlanta we shot some videos we you
know we um we moved them around the city
like we we uh we set up some some
pop-ups for him you know he came to our
studio to mean streets
um he recorded the the thug records that
are on uh I think on mailbox money
um he did those in Mean Streets and um
you know he even like nip for a minute
had a a studio uh that he basically got
the concept for from coming to our
studio to see because we you know the
way we have our [__] set up is like a a
full compound you've seen like how
snoops studio is Snoop as well got the
idea to do his Studio from when he came
to my studio now his [__] is next level
like you know to dog for what he
accomplished but you know
um but yeah this this right here just
came about you know
us going to wakano running in the nip
and here we have Crenshaw you know one
of my one of my favorites it's a studio
that you recorded your [__] and remember
he's like oh this is Nipsey just yeah to
us and then you based off your [__] off
of the way that was designed remember
you're like yo this [__] looks tight I
gotta design my bathroom like this
remember you beat all the Neons and [__]
our friend took that studio over yeah
yeah he took that studio over and uh
it's [__] funny yeah that's crazy
yeah I remember shooting a video for
more or less we shot that in Atlanta it
seemed to me looking from the outside in
like he really had a different
relationship with his fans and a lot of
uh rappers do and the sunset he's like I
could put they could download it for
free or they could pay me a hundred
dollars they're gonna pay it yeah nobody
had ever thought of that before he knew
he was on to it like and they were lined
up around the corner to do it and then
you know me and nip wound up going to
Atlantic around the same time uh nip
didn't announce that he had did a deal
with Atlantic for some time but like
when I first got my anr uh job uh coming
back to Atlantic was right around the
time after Crenshaw where he you know uh
quietly had did a partnership in a deal
with them too and was was in the
building so that was pretty dope
this is this is classic I got to give me
one of these yeah yeah I gotta get one
of these [__] vinyls are so sick all
right I want to switch it up real quick
ready
do you have any siblings did you grow up
by yourself or are you one are you one
of those kids where you're like yeah I
got no siblings my parents buy me
whatever the [__] I want I have a sister
uh older older says we have the same
birthday ah yeah we're nine years apart
exactly sucks for her that's my older
baby brother the baby's got the [__]
birthday now I can only imagine she
that's how she felt yeah she wanted a
bike and she got and they were like oh
you didn't get your bike boo got you a
little brother
I don't want a [__] little brother I
want a bike whack but nine she's too old
to beat you up my sister's three two
years older than me she's beat the [__]
out of me because of that no she she
used to put hands on me a little bit
damn nine years older 18 years of a
nine-year-old
so she was nine so yeah like when I was
probably like four five so she was what
like uh 14 13. okay I imagine that I got
a couple smacks of upside my head but I
love it to death you know we we um so we
didn't grow up like she's not my I'm my
mom's only child
um so uh my father has me and her so we
didn't like spend all of our years under
the same household
um so like when I was with my mom I I
grew up somewhat like an only child but
I wasn't a kid that like got anything I
wanted like you know I was you know I I
got a Nintendo and I got a skateboard
and I got a turntable and thankfully in
a mixer so but then some of that was
even me convincing my grandparents to to
pitch in
oh
30 million U.S Americans are facing
erectile dysfunction on The Daily fellas
you sometimes need a little help in the
bedroom you get a little bit nervous you
need a little bit of help we're here to
save you the doctors at Rex MD will
evaluate you online and there's no need
to go to a doctor's office real FDA
approved medications at the best price
this is what Rex MD is here to help you
with Rex MD makes getting generic and
branded Viagra and Cialis easy online
the prescription included delivered
discreetly and directly to your door no
waiting rooms no embarrassing trips to
the doctor's office no insurance no
co-pays just you and your ED medication
so take advantage of the best deal ever
and is up to 90 off also pay as little
as two dollars per doses with our
exclusive link so to take advantage of
this limited time deal go to rexmd.com
forward slash dope Ed can mess up all
kinds of relationships and things in
life we want to avoid that Rex MD is
making it easy and simple with their
online platform with just a few clicks
of a button you're talking to a medical
professional you guys are putting
together a plan they're shipping your
prescriptions to your door discreetly
directly to you within two days act now
to take advantage of this deal by going
to rexmd.com forward slash dope our
exclusive deal will save you up to 90
which means you can pay as little as two
dollars per dosage on generic Viagra
versus ninety dollars starter packs of
generic Viagra in Seattle are now
available to our listeners to get
started remember that's rexmd.com
forward slash dope and that's going to
save you 90 off plus a free gift and
remember your partner will thank you
you can
see I always want to know the rules of
fools were you the kids set like
reselling candy bars and [__] picking up
cans trying to make money that was that
was when I was here everything was that
you I was a hustler as a kid yeah for
sure even that five or six type [__]
well I remember like one of my first
gigs was like a paper route
um I had to wake up like 5 a.m in the
morning and go on this paper route with
this like kind of like just overweight
white lady that worked lived in in the
neighborhood at the time I didn't last
long on that
um but you know I I didn't start really
having jobs I didn't start really
working until like my teen years uh what
was that first one though
my first job
was I think it was I was working on
South Street
um I got a gig on South Street in Philly
which is very well known
um and it was that it was at a this
store called Inferno which was like
known for like piercings and like kind
of like rock and roll stuff but they
opened up another side and they started
selling like hip-hop gear and like
graffiti caps and mixtapes and stuff
like that and so they hired me to like
work at the the front of that how are
you then uh maybe like uh 15 16. ah see
that I remember that first like this is
my job I'm basically a [__] adult so
I know you get that first feeling and
you're basically annoying child because
you're so much older than you yeah I
just want to like get the feel I always
you know everybody asked like so what
was it like but I always don't want to
ask like tell me about your childhood
yeah cause I feel like it's kind of
generic but yo you got older sisters you
speak share to you it's always a good
icebreak nah nobody really that's not
that's not a question I get asked a lot
and that's why I wanted to ask like I
wanted to speak different like what's
something you don't hear yeah you're
gonna be some childhood [__] all right
so your first job you're at the piercing
store yeah hip-hop store yeah um I read
it online obviously but I wanted to ask
you got into music before you even got
there
yeah well I I started like being a
connoisseur of yeah well I mean I went
to go see the movie Juice so that was
what first inspired me to be a DJ like
seeing that movie but you know I was
into music before that obviously like
you know growing up just watching the
box and and uh Rap City and young TV
raps and [__] like that and just my
parents both had like record collection
so I used to play with their vinyl and
stuff like that juice uh is you still
one of your favorite movies of all time
oh absolutely yeah I just put my
daughter on to her she's 14 I like
forced her to watch it oh did you yeah I
gotta show you some some dope [__] after
that top three movies of all time all
time does it have to be comedies because
it's hard to put comedies in because
you're like that's my favorite comedy
but you don't want to put in your top
three yeah because I have like top three
gangster flicks exactly the top three
movies that aren't comedies
they could be funny but they're not like
comedies so I'll go
Good Fellas
I'll go Usual Suspects oh good [__] and
um
think I'll go juice for for you know the
inspiration but I'm a movie buff I could
do this same right here I'm like the
Cable Guy in my head yeah I can do the
[__] I got the weird memory all right so
I could go City a guy City guy's a good
[__] movie bro even though I gotta
read subtitles I'm like yeah I'm still
stuck yeah I'll watch it twice just to
watch everything again that's a good
[__] movie yeah that's crazy usual
suspect something people don't ever
throw out there man yeah well another
interesting tidbit is that
you know at the end of every gangster
girls when I saying like that we gone
like that comes from you that is gone
Crush that [__] movie yes I was like
seven years old when I watched it and
when I watched his foot turn straight I
went I [__] ran around the room like
there's no [__] way yeah
one of my favorite movies me too I got
the show in uh no DVD that's where I got
then like that we going from no [__]
that's a good one yeah I'm the same dude
with movies like my mom was kind of like
on drugs and she's like watch TV I'm
like don't trip I will I watch them for
days so I all those movies all those old
school [__] all right you like old
movies then I like all movies I mean
when you say oh how old are we like uh
world according to GARP old with Robin
Williams
um I'm familiar I I seen it but it's
been a while but yeah okay definitely
all right yeah I'll go I can go anywhere
when it comes to film okay all right I
just wanted I wanted before I I thought
I was gonna be a DJ like and because my
older sister was actually into film so I
I wanted to be like a film director like
I thought I was gonna like go to NYU
film school and really do film yeah yeah
yeah that's how I started off I wanted I
was making little shorts that so I
started at everything like 10 years ago
I was making little shorts and making uh
I was just like repurposing scenes but
it was almost parody and it was with
toys and nugs and I would dig like oh
that's fire ramble First Blood uh you uh
Reservoir Dogs when he cuts off
marvinash's ear crazy but I bought
little chairs tied nugs to it took like
scenes
a little ketchup on the ground that's
how I started off like other people
director or some [__] that's exactly
what I said that's fine all right cool
man I like this Direction all right all
right so you guys wanted to I don't know
maybe you haven't been asked you know
all right oh Truman Show It's gotta be
my favorite movie ever what's so ill
about The Truman Show is like how
like how it ahead of his time it was and
like where we are today in society like
like foreshadowing yeah like the
foreshadowing and that I've never
thought about that is so impeccable it's
like you watch you watch movies like yo
do y'all just really know and want to
just like thank you give us the hints
like when Minority Report came out I'm
like yo are y'all just tell them yeah
y'all just showing us what we what we're
getting used to like or like when I saw
like um Ready Player one that was a good
movie and I'd be telling people like yo
that like when I seen the metaverse come
out I was like yo that's what it's going
to be like like people just living in a
whole nother world inside this [__]
these [__] goggles so exactly like
when you think about movies you think
about that I think about that all the
time like it's clearly like the Truman
shows is like so like that's the world
we live in like everything it's right
now it's accurate everyone lives their
own [__] Truman Show and I think the
good afternoon good evening and night
and he leaves I think that's what
everybody's trying to do right now and
the world is [__] up and there's [__]
in the news there's balloons and this
like yo what's really going on someone
found the door is what happened right
that's what I think is real [__] so all
right yeah I had to change that for my
first my favorite movie it was Forrest
Gump but I had I had to go foreign
with the freeze frame and then I was
[__] and then freeze framed and then I
came up I feel like it was the same
movie Just gangster Wall Street dudes
yeah pulling legal [__] yeah when you
said that I couldn't like unsee it I
said it was like he is Ray Liotta it's
just Ray Liotta or Leonardo DiCaprio's
Mark scorses and Little Ray Liotta new
uh Robert De Niro because those guys are
getting up there and obviously Ray
Liotta was gone yeah I just feel like
Leonardo Capri is going to be Jack
Nicholson around 10 years he's just
going to be that cool [__] yeah
yeah he is he is right that guy for sure
The Shining like [__] I got Jack
Torrance on my wall I got a lifelike toy
I got sick ass like sculpted toy of him
in my house did you like the sequel uh I
didn't watch it because I didn't want to
get ruined bro you know a lot of people
didn't like it but I feel like it had
some ill ill parts to it talking about
where Angie's growing up or uh yeah
what's the name of this name it's kind
of different names yeah it's a different
name something something it's the it's
not dude from Star Wars he's the guy now
right yeah damn all right he was the kid
no movies no he was the yeah he was a
little kid yeah he was a kid and he
still had the uh do you remember the
first fire starter of course of course
the new one sucked I remember yeah I
remember going to see watching that [__]
all the time like you know what I really
want I really really really really
really want someone to do I really feel
like it's time for them to make
remake Back to the Future like
because if you think it's so crazy when
you think about it like in Back to the
Future came out 85 almost 40 years ago
right 85 and then they went back to 55
so like if some if we were to make let's
say Back to the Future one the new ones
come out in like 2025 that means they
would literally go back to 95. so
imagine like in the movies 95 feeling
like how
1955 was to us in 85 like I'm sure it
would be dope as fire it would be dope
you know I was saying the other day
remember that show celebrity death match
of course I think if they brought that
back today yeah it'd be hard people
would lose their [__] over that that was
a fun yeah why did that ever got
canceled that was super I mean I mean I
can see live right yeah but it was good
[__] man and then we go comedies what
are we talking we're talking Coming to
America We Do America too was not bad
it wasn't I had to give it a chance he
didn't make me upset Wesley Snipes was
kind of funny
it didn't kill me like Angry brother
like Anchorman 2 Anchorman 2 was bad
yeah Anchorman one is a classic Step
Brothers Step Brothers of course
bridesmaids bridesmaid I just recently
watched I didn't I wasn't sure about it
I wasn't sure and I was like what was I
waiting on there I [__] up yeah
foreign
what I was thinking about the other day
I think Austin Powers might have been
one of the best trilogies ever really do
it all three times yeah all three of
them were funny as [__] like they [__]
with us you see the dumb and dumber's
attempt yeah yeah I don't know what
that's about it yeah but no the other
ones were to get three best Trilogy I
don't know I might have to go to Star
Wars Star Wars if you want to be talking
true or Godfather Godfather is probably
the best Trilogy like when we're talking
one two three Back to the Future is good
Back to the Future is good Star Wars is
is good and then the three Trill like
the fact that it's three trilogies is
pretty intense and [__] my brain's going
blank I can't think of a really really
good Trilogy it's not that many I mean
yeah it's really it's truly not yeah
godfather has to be the big the best so
if you watch a lot of movies I was
thinking the other day you ever seen
American me of course I feel like
American me to Mexicans is what Italians
means Godfather means Italians huh
really and then I think that
blood and blood out is what the same
feeling that Italians think when they
watch Good Fellas like the street
version and then the world takeover
version I was thinking that the other
day like there has to be the comparison
they're all good [__] movies yeah
Classics
you could do a whole breakdown in that
[__] I could tell you a hundred times I
love that movie yeah all right all right
sorry enough of the movie talk I just
wanted to see yeah
I'm a lot of guests are really on that
level
my account maybe he was on a little bit
yeah no dude no one's ever on the movie
[__] oh and I feel like I can not judge
a person feel like yo you like that
movie oh you do you want to hit this
what else that's that's that's how me
and Jack Harlow like outside of music
when the first time he came we met at
Mean Street Studios like when we sat
down and we chopped it up he was like
what are you into and I was like man I
watch a lot of movies and he was like oh
where he was like I don't know if he
asked me like tell me a movie you
wouldn't think that I wouldn't know or
if he just asked me about movies but I
mentioned this movie to him called E2 my
tombien and he like he couldn't believe
that I was that DJ Drama Mr gangster
girls was familiar with YouTube uh
matambien and like blew him away and he
was like all right I'm ready to sign did
that make you like him more though
um like what what Drew you to him
besides like oh you're I could see why
he just I just liked his energy as his
Vibe like you know he was very
comfortable in his own skin even even
coming in and it's like like somewhat
nerdy white kid that literally looked
like Napoleon Dynamite at the time but
like you know like he came in looking
like that and saying I want to be one of
the greatest rappers of all time and I
was like wow that's impressive like and
he had the bars to back it up how long
ago was that 20 I met Jack in like 2017.
and that's right when you were starting
your label right we had already started
the label we started generation now in
2015 when we signed Uzi
um
so yeah so the label was already up and
running but we jack we we launched as a
joint venture with Atlantic when we
signed Jack what's it like being with
Lil Uzi vert's career or something so
early on to where it's at now he's a
he's a uh the youths [__] they prayed
to this [__] guy I swear to God bro
my little every young I have so many
younger brothers and sisters a lot of
them in high school and it's like
I don't I didn't know like the impact
yeah it's [__] Global yeah he's like
a goat to the to the kids it's crazy
yeah it's dope I mean
again somebody that I met super early on
like [__] it was he
was probably like what 18 19 if we met
him
um and like you know he the the the the
guy that he is now he he was then just
with a lot less money but
but just super energetic you know like
came came on my tour bus cracked some
jokes on my jeans and like I was like
yeah I like this kid like he he had he
has it you know he he always he knew
like I'm gonna be like I'm gonna be a
rock star like he told us from day one
you know he had a vision like he was
very you know he was very tunnel vision
in a lot of ways on on where he wanted
to go with his career and you know
thankfully like myself Cannon and Lake
like we
we allowed and we gave him the shoulders
to stand on to get there like a lot
faster than you know I think he would
have been regardless but like you know
like uh us being in his corner you know
allowing him to be in Mean Street
Studios where he was he was meeting his
you know some of the some of his idols
who became his peers that he looked up
to like meeting Thug earlier meeting
whiz you know and going on tour and just
like you know uh uh Lake really like
putting together his uh uh his touring
um you know layout from early on and
mastering that part of it and Canon with
with uh you know providing his sound and
you know what they accomplished within
the studio like it it's really dope to
think back and you know think about
those early years and and to look at
where he is now like like wow like I
feel you know it's it's a good feeling
it feels very accomplished you have to
be sometimes when you buy yourself like
I [__] called it you got at least
at least like you had to be like damn my
[__] brain sometimes because
sometimes I'll say some [__] like it
happened
I do it more in public like I told you
so like
but behind closed doors I'm more like
what the [__] am I gonna do now like I
do that all the time what's next like
[__] like
we just
made an artist that went diamond like
what do we do next
oh [__]
we just had another Superstar artist
[__] am I gonna do next oh [__] I just
want a Grammy
[__] am I gonna do next all the pressure
keep it going I do I've done that my
whole career like even after we made
sure I made tribe or die I was like damn
what the [__] am I gonna do now like and
it's not even for the it's more for
yourself to not because I understand
what you're saying because we make so
much stuff and it's like
I gotta top that again that's what
that's how that's what I do behind
closed doors oh I'm always challenging
myself for like thinking like all right
like all right what am I what I'm gonna
do next yeah to impress yourself but it
keeps coming apparently I mean you've
gone through so many different waves of
music it's incredible I mean like to and
to still be here we just did a TED Talk
and like we ended it off with and it was
about for like creative entrepreneurs
how to make money through the internet
and stuff like that we ended it off with
the one thing nobody can teach you is
how to leverage your relationships and
that's what it seems like like you're a
master black belt level person out doing
that to keep like we were saying in the
Ted talk you don't always have to be the
star of the show sometimes it's really
valuable to have these skills that serve
other people you can tap into their
careers absolutely and just keep it
going you don't even don't even have a
run you just happening everybody's
running right you add value to whoever
you have a relationship with so it's
like exactly not a lot of people out
there that have withstood the test of
time and done that for so long and like
leveraged so many different
relationships that's something I take
pride in I mean like it's something
early on in my career I was like
you know relevancy was has always been
very important to me like
okay you got here how do you stay here
so to have accomplished that and like
even at times when you know I mean the
game is is a roller coaster like you
have hot moments you have cold moments
then you get hot and you might you know
be lukewarm or and get hot again so you
know to be here in 2023 like
you know probably the hottest I've ever
been after
23 years in the game like 30 years djan
like it's it's quite the Testament you
know and a lot of it like
when I think about it it just comes from
like the love and the passion and like
you know for me doing it for the for the
the the genuine reasons you know what I
mean like the money is great like the
fame is dope like the the extra stuff
that comes with the the traveling or you
know being around beautiful women or
like you know just the accolades like
all that [__] is is is
great to have but just the just the
passion that like being a little kid who
wanted to get my my name on a [__]
flyer and like now to sit here and like
have a legendary album with DJ Drama
presents and there's multiples of this
like I have a Grammy in my house like
that [__] is like that's what keeps me
going like you know like when I when
it's all said and done you know and I'm
at that point in my life where I've
probably lived like half my life God
bless you know what I'm saying so you
know even when I talk on tapes now like
you know the things I say at 45 I wasn't
saying in 20 and I'm like but I'm also
thinking about like wow what I'm you
know I'm I'm leaving behind or I'm I'm
leaving a legacy of of things that you
know hopefully 100 150 years 200 years
from now people will still be listening
to and studying and talking about
beautiful you articulated that well
that's how I feel about I just want to
leave some [__] for people go that fool
was hard yeah that's how you live
forever you know what I mean because
it's like you're not on there just
talking you're really explaining about
the artist that's the thing that like
to me [__] that's missing now it's like
how Bruce Buffer brings out a fighter
like the Fighter's not gonna sit there
and tell you all about himself yeah he
needs a proper introduction to do his
thing uh thank you I love that yeah I
mean that that's how I feel you know and
and like even when I see like comments
like I wish drama would shut the [__] up
or like what why is he talking on the
tapes I'm like yo listen like if I
didn't add some type of value there's no
way that this many artists or I would
have been able to can be talking over
your favorite artist's music for this
long long period of time if I wasn't
saying something of substance and like
you know I try to I try to approach it
in that way where it's like you know I'm
adding value to the music like you know
I'm an instrument in my in itself like
with what with the words I speak like my
[__] just doesn't rhyme but I say from
some very eloquent you know words my
[__] just doesn't run though I like that
do you freestyle that [__] or is it
pretty thought out
um a little bit of both a majority of it
is freestyle for the most part where
like I'll kind of just go in
um listen to the music and go off the
head but every now and then you know
I'll I'll make note of some certain
things that I may want to say or you
know a fine inspiration in various ways
like like when I first did uh Dream
Chasers too uh with Meek I was just
randomly at an airport getting on a
flight and Time Magazine had this uh
cover
cover Edition about sleep and I I think
I was high at the time and I was like oh
I need to get that and like I literally
read through this whole article about
like the process of sleep and the things
about you know dreaming and things like
that so when I when I'm on Meek's tape
and I'm like they say your brain's most
creative and and well you're sleeping
like I literally got that from reading
the Time Magazine so it come it comes
from all different places
before we wrap up yeah there's just a
little little segment we'll do we'll run
through it real quick uh it's called who
are you in the 90s and I think it's
perfect I think it's a perfect episode
for it so we'll just ask you two things
and you just pick one or the other
that's literally all it is ready for
that yeah or before sorry before I
forget you ever seen that movie uh
things that do in Denver when you're
dead I have I don't really remember it
but I've definitely seen it okay yeah
that was an old movie that was a dope
90s flick yeah all right who was in that
was uh Garcia Andy Garcia Andy Garcia uh
uh Steve Buscemi oh okay yep yeah let's
go [__] a movie yeah all right run it
for real in the 90s all right so from
who you actually were in the 90s from
your perspective as you in the 90s your
preferences now any knowledge you know
now like who
what did you like 1995 what would you
have said back then VH1 or MTV
um
what is it tough one
because VH1 used to have some [__] in
the 90s like before it became reality TV
but yum TV wraps was on MTV so I would
probably say MTV more impactful yeah
from a hip-hop perspective but like VH1
used to like
but I'd probably go on TV Tupac or baby
in the 90s Biggie got a classic track
from biggie favorite I mean I remember
the first time I heard dreams of [__]
r b [__] like when it was still called
that on a mixtape
um I remember the first time I heard
unbelievable on a mixtape
um
you know even the
um biggie freestyling over the classic
death row instrumentals like obscure
biggie [__] yeah yeah I was him and
Tupac Together live of course
um I remember there was a song with him
and Tupac
it was was it a Heavy D song but that
was off of mixtape too it was a couple
other people on there but they had a
record together and then you know
definitely like one more chance remix
like summer 95 that [__] was the
soundtrack to to Philly like that's all
you heard out of every single car
we could do a whole episode on Philly
rap too I go super deep with the same
property and that whole
yeah Philly has some of the best rappers
in the world yeah yeah
our most largest city ever and even in
podcasting now with million dollars
worth of game while I was helping out
you know tons of people in the industry
he's only got us the Ted Talk actually
oh that's what's up yeah he's only
hooked us up with a great guy great
friend
um Pennywise or Chucky we gotta go it
you gotta say it Tim remember Tim
Curry's movie it yeah I didn't really
like the movie that much but the but
imma go it only because if we talk in
90s we're talking Stephen King and
Stephen King is way more impactful than
[__] Child's Play like just in
general like all as bodies of work
movies and books like Stephen King is
the goat
in the 90s people don't even know like
Stand By Me is a great movie and people
grew up to bang marry Rebecca romaine
and that story that kid that story isn't
from Stephen King like yeah the book
yeah almost everything is written by
this [__] man you just don't know
it's an adaptation from his book well he
grew up who grew up to remember the fat
kid from yeah you stand by me yeah
that's uh the actor from Tomcats the big
buff dude yeah he's married to Rebecca
Romaine oh [__] that came pretty kid
that's the same [__] fat kid so when
I remember when I watched my dad that's
the fact that they're picking up they do
that to me back in like you know who he
is now like that's the guy from Tomcats
I got hope damn you're on your way yeah
go home all right go for it in the 90s
Michael Jackson or Michael Jordan were
you more into
oh that's a good one
in the 90s I'd probably have to say
Jordan
because you know the 90s was a weird
time for Mike Jackson like you know
early 90s he was still on top of the
world like when like like when when when
um
what so I guess bag came out late 80s
dangerous came out early 90s so like
remember when like black or white first
premiered like the video on TV I
remember well I remember watching that
after The Simpsons or the Super Bowl or
some [__] it came out but then like like
then like mid 90s Mike started going
through like a kind of a weird phase
where it was kind of you know people
were kind of like on the fence with a
little on the fence with Mike so Jordan
pretty much dominated and ruled the 90s
where he was like the goat of all goats
during the night you got a great [__]
memory like your memory is down to the
years and seasons and [__] I have a
photography memory it's a blessing and a
curse it's it's picture perfect
when it comes to music and movies and
[__] like that like like things like you
know Don yeah I'm good I remember years
very I just remember how old I was like
I do the math like I was seven when
Space Jam came out uh 96 yeah you know
I'm like boom you know who's the king of
that [__] it's [__] Tyler the Creator
really that good oh my God like
that [__] will [__] tell you what
page the Missy Elliott interview in herb
magazine was like what like [__] what
month what page like Edition number like
he's his brain isn't insane when it
comes to [__] like that that's kind of
tight and like I said it helps bro
it [__] helps and it sucks I think
he'll remember track number six
oh that [__] on the Black Street album
yeah if you can see it I can remember
everything but
you know what I mean like I can't
remember what the [__] page that's
good when you're a rapper though you
gotta remember all your lyrics and [__]
that's helpful yeah he's like a he's
like a music rain man he's Dustin Hall
he should be yeah you know what just
keep going last one in the 90s step by
step where Family Matters
excuse me Full House Full House Full
House for Family Matters
wow
Full House was big
um
I'ma probably safe Full House only
because
Full House came out
earlier in the 90s when I was still
watching sitcoms
um
feel like
I feel like full Full House came before
Family Matters so but I think so by the
time Family Matters was on I wasn't
really watching television the same way
like so yeah like Full House was because
Full House reminds me of like the cheers
Family Ties yeah still cheerful and
upbeat and [__] yeah generic wasn't the
start of the show at first I'm gonna say
this Urkel has always been the star of
the show
I just said the other day how a
legendary would be Ed O'Neill on here
and I'd wear a no ma'am shirt right when
he sat down that'd be fine like Kelly
Bundy She's So Dope I uh I spoke to Joy
but Bundy I was on it was in uh West
Hollywood and I was at my homie's shop
and he goes Bud's uh he's like David's
here I go
there's a picture of me like a little
kid he's so little so I'm like yeah like
ah dude it wasn't one of the best days
of my life I lost my [__] only FaceTime
me with Eddie Winslow one time lost my
I'm the sitcom 90. that's my [__] that's
what my mom likes just sit here I'll be
back and that's what I did I watched I
watched that [__] so I get what you mean
by Full House 90s is probably my
favorite decade just because those are
my first years those are my four minute
years yeah
um I know that was not on there but uh
Fresh Prince obviously I love that
[__] show I don't know if you watch
Fresh Prince heavy I watched Fresh
Prince all right my videographer my my
personal videographers from Russia
Nikita shout out to Nikita
I said you know like Fresh Prince style
and he goes what does that mean so I
haven't tell you this yet I go you know
like Fresh Prince of Bel-Air he goes
what is this and I go Will Smith he goes
oh Will Smith yeah I go Fresh Prince he
never heard of it you've never heard of
Fresh Prince and he's like what is it
about and I started explaining this man
like it's about a kid from Philadelphia
right he goes to play basketball and
then he gets beat up and his mom's like
Oh hell no you're gonna live with your
uncle where and Bella and then I
realized this is the [__] theme song
I'm just [__] saying it I just played
the theme song for him I showed him and
when he was starting to get spun you
know smoking foreign
up and he's like this is Will Smith and
when he's done the head shake and he
goes That's well Samantha go yeah bro
that's what I'm trying to tell you he
thought he was just like a action hero
are you going well are you going Fresh
Prince or you're going Martin
oh Fresh Prince for me man Martin which
uh my neck neighbor name was uh
come on Shanaynay they always called her
Shanaynay when I lived in Fresno and I
watched Martin with my mom and I just
thought it was the coolest thing that
our neighbors was this you know what I
mean was the same my name is Martin
Lawrence get out of here my Lawrence
O'Neill yeah but technically I'm a Will
Smith fan wow
his wife's name is April O'Neil yeah
by association there's turtles not the
porn star could you imagine going to TSA
like right
take your [__] back all right
but yeah I'd explain in the key to what
fresh prince was it was a [__] epic I
explain All American [__] to him don't
film gangsters when we're doing that
Vlog there's a big ass game bangers I'm
like oh and Nikita come over here he
goes what you want me to crawl they
[__] [__] [__] bitched and we
wrapped up
anyway
I like teaching of America sure one
thing I want to touch on before we wrap
up
something that nobody that ever gets any
shine in the rap industry mixtape
industry but is super important which is
the graphic artist yeah cover art yeah
which has changed the whole course of my
life yeah mixtape art yeah is
there like certain people you've worked
with your whole career are you
constantly finding new people because
it's such a big part of each project
it's changed over the years but the guy
who did the majority of my legendary
covers is a guy by the name of Rob
petrozo
um his company at the time was called
lights out he is now gone on to do
amazing things with so many corporations
like
Nike I don't even know where to start
like the stuff that he does now like in
the world is like literally doing like
commercial uh things but he started out
doing mixtape designs and graphics and
you know he was he was a big part of My
Success because you know the covers were
like the hook would capture people you
know you when you saw the dedication
cover like you know he came up with that
concept just like the the black and
white and the drawing of it like to just
to this day to watch the influence of
that cover and to see like people
recreated or things of that nature like
or like so many of the gangster girls
covers like and he didn't just do my
stuff like he did a lot of other
people's other DJs stuff too
um and then uh later on like there was a
a kid eight who who's actually from uh
the UK who was I changed some of the the
the style and design of of mixtape
covers but but yeah I mean over the
years I've worked with various people I
definitely you know Rob is like my guy
like when it comes to the classics but
yeah I mean they you're right that the
the designers and the graphic designers
those are like
um Untold Heroes unsung heroes that
don't get a lot of the credit that they
just they deserve that you know they
they're the ones that make these
legendary covers that you know make us
want to hang these up and just pieces of
art yeah exactly truly and like like I
was saying earlier this is the best way
to get tangible support the artist I
feel like this is the best way you could
possibly support an artist you can
always skip on Spotify but I feel like
when you put something on like you
appreciate it you sit down you listen
especially like a piece of vinyl because
you're just like it's it's fun yeah you
it makes you feel like a kid kind of
like yeah of course put the needle on
you just let it run like you know what
I'm saying yeah I gotta get I gotta get
a turntable just for this I just gotta
yeah this is fine I'm gonna order one of
these
well tell me tell me if I got a good
deal that he made it in red
yeah I know yeah
you did an interview about that and he
just said he's like red is just in
marketing it's like why is the color of
a stop sign radar yeah even thinking
about it that he made
the Crenshaw
cover red like
crossing boundaries you would think it
would have been blue yeah because I
remember when we did I don't remember if
it was on purpose or
if he asked but like when we first did
Jesus Streets is Watching it was all
blue
um so yeah interesting yeah I think it
makes it more interesting that they did
it all like fire engine red and [__]
fire if I shot the G Perico too you know
he has his uh line on right now called
This is a blue t-shirt and he has like
it's called This is a blue t-shirt it's
called This is a blue t-shirt but it'll
be like a red t-shirt
a a white T-shirt or a cream t-shirt
like a liar liar [__] this is blue this
is a t-shirt yeah like uh where I'm from
from the central California but I was
trying to explain to my homie the other
day because he's from Florida like I
can't you know we're allowed to wear
blue or red to school like you can't
wear numbers or or teams of any kind or
hats that they're not allowed to unless
they have the School logo that's it
that's how I grew up so I like then you
could wear no blue or red to school no
so I have red shoes on today it feels so
[__] weird like I remember I told you
I wore them the other day I'm like this
is the first time I wore colors of mine
[__] I can't imagine that's so crazy
having to go to school and not being
able to wear blue or red just wear black
all day black and then Green Bay Packer
Jersey that's the only like your
statement when you got your car that was
blocked oh yeah I wrapped my car blue
and I but I never drove back home back
up North Carolina I'm gonna get right
off the free I'm gonna get [__] with
something's gonna happen like this is
not worth it I'd rather just rent a car
so I just ran into the [__] car
but it's just where are you from and
it just happens so when you guys are
talking about I'm like [__] dude imagine
we're living in here yeah that's a whole
different story from where I live you
know what I mean where I'm from it
wasn't like that in Buffalo yeah I know
I know it's [__] snow it's just snow
and [__] heartache and [__] but this
this whole [__] like I didn't realize
until like really researching for this
interview like my whole path has been
built around the mixtape I didn't
realize all the time bro like you'll
appreciate this in 2005 yeah I started
recording I started to just rap my ass
off once I was playing college
basketball stop started rapping and [__]
started the basement started to get in
studios decided I'm gonna put out a
mixtape okay so I connected with this
dude out of Brooklyn jailbreak records
probably never heard of them got 5 000
mixtapes for five thousand dollars wow
meaning I went out and took a loan out
of the bank 5 000 cash money orders at
the gas station send it down to Brooklyn
we drove down there my dad's station
wagon picked up 5 000 CDs the inserts
the discs the cases and he had Capone
hosting
Capone Noriega hosted my [__] wow so now
imagine we popped that [__] back I
hadn't even heard it 20 tracks I sent it
to him Capone hosted the whole [__] he
did the artwork I'm driving back they
brought in the CNN Capone or Diego the
instrumental he just comes on Buffalo
wblk now I'm I'm co-signing this [__] so
me and my boys are driving back to
Buffalo listening to this [__] for the
first time was iconic right yeah we came
back took him into record theater took
him into all the corner stores got them
all off he got them all off and then
just started dropping mixtapes but I
started doing the covers yeah and then I
built a business you started like
designing the covers okay yes I ended up
building a business called drastic
Graphics okay so after a bunch of years
I built that then I got a deal with DJ
ski you signed me to like a record deal
and I moved out here but then I started
doing basically somewhat similar to what
you did I got out here yeah DJ ski
became a TV host basically the studio
got moved out of the ski lodge like a
week after I moved here and [__] so then
I linked up with a bunch of really big
Comedians and I started playing that
role behind the scenes uh for a lot of
Comedians and podcasters and then I kind
of put the music on hold but then we
came back and we started this podcast
it's so [__] well you talk about
stories
just like a mixtape that was my thing
yeah it was a real way for somebody
because I knew I could hustle hired her
before like the internet was so there
this was like early MySpace I'm like I
can outwork everybody yeah no problem
it's through these mixtapes so when you
got the 5000 where they already put
together no no me and my boys had to do
it yeah I had to do that too I would
have to put the inserts in and you got
just the discs just the inserts fill up
the whole [__] car yeah you would get
if you get the this this what is the
spool of the CDs and then the cases and
then the covers and you have to yeah put
the cover in CD I mean I got to a point
where I had interns who used to do all
that [__] but I definitely started out
doing that [__] myself but like at the
Ted Talk we try to tell people like all
these skills playing this kind of role
people don't really ever you don't they
don't tell you this in college think
about it like that all right but like
having these kind of like they don't see
that leg work like they don't see the
the the the the the the hustle and the
grind that goes into like the early year
the formative years of like what it
takes to be where we're at you know what
I'm saying hey so and that's that's
that's part of the you know that's part
of the journey like you know I I some
people are lucky to be able to skip
those steps I'm thankful enough that I
went through the stairs I went through
all that I've been through all every
phase of it to see it I think you
appreciated it because when people
understand that that it inspires them
even more sure and when you keep
leveling up they notice that and it
makes them want to yeah of course of
course
um uh before we get out here where can
everybody find you at
um music uh online social media my new
album I'm really like that next week
because this comes out on Monday so
it'll be what like eight days later the
31st yep so wow that'll be available on
all March 31st four year anniversary of
his death too
that you know kind of pick the uh
uh a a date that you know has some
significance that we we lost the legend
you know what I'm saying so and the
legend is on my album
um so we're definitely going to sell
he's got a verse from celebrating him uh
uh on that 331 yeah 331 and then um you
know I got a multitude of projects that
are out now that are coming out you know
definitely uh look for from for any
anything with DJ Drama you can probably
roll your window down at any Hood
somebody's probably blasting against the
grills uh generation now
um compilations on the way uh Lil Uzi
vert new album new music from Jack
Harlow uh we Sonny digital new project
come in uh carvina uh our female R B
artist and then we're we're looking to
sign a whole bunch of new uh artists
coming up soon too so that's your what's
next got a lot of things yeah you know
what I'm saying like you're saying
there's not a podcast coming out soon oh
[__] what's it called
um DJ dramas gangster girls podcast
um I don't want to give too many details
but it's definitely going to be special
nice yeah it's gonna be special so I got
a lot of a lot of fun good things in the
works
man of course always on Spotify YouTube
Everything DJ Drama there he is good
[__] so 331 everybody go check that out
it's gonna drop on I'm saying I'm
assuming every yeah every streaming
platform
good [__] man this was fun thank you
very much this is Chill nah I appreciate
it I'm uh I'm happy to talk movies with
somebody all right
it was Dustin Hall nobody ever knows
your references and [__] yeah my mama
yeah my mom that's about it man so I
appreciate you thank you very much
appreciate it thank you sir appreciate
it guys this has been the dope as usual
podcast for Marty from DJ Drama and I
have a dope ass day love
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie